the Commonwealth is just the polite way
that we that we say we used to own the
world you're from a country that some of
us used to own I
presume for which I can only apologize
so my my South African friend what
what's your what's your name Candace
Candice that's beautiful that's a lovely
name and and the people here with night
s sister brother partner that was in
order of preference for the
answer friends friends they together
they are together though that's all
right you know it's no no barrier what
uh how how do you how so you're wearing
a hoodie that says New York City which
suggests you're not from here right
you're it's like whenever I see an
American wearing an Oxford University
sweater I go up to them and I go oh what
what when were you there and then they
go I was there for a week on holiday and
I go did a degree there [__] so [__]
and then they go sorry aren't you
telling jokes for money and I go yes
that is that is true that's not didn't
work out that well so you are you all
South
Africans no you just no Chris no we're
morally morally
safe Australia and New Zealand oh this
is beautiful like
really I love it's that's yeah that's
what we call the Commonwealth is just
the polite way that we that we say we
used to own the
world the Commonwealth yeah we rebranded
the empire did it work I don't know um
the Sun never sets on the British
Conwell this is really lovely because
the thing is you're from South Africa
you're from Australia you're from New
Zealand I'm from the United Kingdom but
to all the Americans our accents sound
exactly the
same I guarantee everywhere you go
they're like oh my God you're English
because everyone thinks I'm a gay
Australian that's what they
think this is really lovely it's like a
[__] model un this is brilliant uh um
trying to look around like yeah I mean
you're from a country that some of us
used to own I
presume for which I can only
apologize so let's let's let's chat to
my Commonwealth friends what um uh we'll
go down the line going to ask you the
the No No I'm just going to ask you the
jobs that you do what is it that you do
ier you are a finance lawyer for for
good people or bad people it depends on
who's paying me most so bad people yeah
okay Finance lawyer a South African
Finance lawyer we have an Australian who
does what Finance Finance okay I mean
you got used to work together you used
to work together why who got
fired he now lives in New York he now
lives in New York and you live in Sydney
which is but but then you're the austral
so [__]
what and then and then you are a I'm an
advertising an ad in advertising ooh
what's the what's the biggest client
that you you've
got uh she quickly makes up a
client work for Apple they're pretty big
yeah heard them what's Apple let me look
it up on my
phone great okay so you do advertising
for Apple you're Finance lawyers I
imagine that when you were younger
growing up you did not want to do these
jobs now shaking their head going
[__] anything else Chris would I
would end it if I wasn't so filthy rich
um money does not buy happiness why are
you giggling over
there um so what did you want to be when
you were little I actually want to be an
actress you actually wanted to be an
actress why did you have to clarify it
with that I actually wanted to be an act
I'm like all these [__] losers and
Pretenders who were like I want to make
it a Broadway what who which and then
you saying you wanted to be an actress
as well you know cuz now we're going to
call them actors regardless of gender
and you're like [__] that no and also we
should be segregated in South Africa
again Chris I believe there should be
don't Shar that that's her opinion not
mine it's not your opinion who was your
favorite
actress who was my favorite Merill
Merill Street [__] she's the classic
one is she um what what did you want to
be why are you looking at your
girlfriend um probably something in film
probably something in film yeah
directing or
directing camam maybe or cameraman it's
a big step
down probably directing cameraman uh
just press the red button you know and
just stand there great okay what's your
favorite film oh um you're so dramatic
ah how would you expect me to answer
this one of the Godfathers one of the
Godfathers well which one the first one
okay yeah I was going to say if you said
three you're a [__] nut what
I love
it I love Sophia cppa she's an excellent
directress and
then and then what uh what uh what did
you want to be I wanted to be a pilot
you wanted to be a pilot for which
airline New Zealand Air New Zealand yeah
it's pretty good they got if you Air New
Zealand if you buy um two seats in a
three you can pay a little bit more to
buy the third seat and they turn into a
life flat bed for you which is you know
she's actually started training she's
actually started training to be a pilot
that's pretty
[__] that's pretty cool just just
know that you know every time people are
on a plane and they hear a woman's voice
in the cockpit they do go a little bit
like oh you don't get many of those do
you I uh I love that um I would be a
terrible pilot a I'm colorblind B I'm
I'm I'm too calm in difficult situations
and I think you know like you need a
certain level of calmness but I have too
much I I I had a dream where I was
piloting a a jumbo jet and both engines
failed and I came on the intercom and I
genuinely said ladies and gentlemen we
are beginning our
descent just calm him down right that
you
know okay so we have some some Financial
lawyers and an ier for Apple but you
want to be a pilot and you are training
to make that happen so [__] apple right
you know they don't need you uh you
wanted to be a director or a cameraman
on The Godfather and you you wanted to
be an actress like Merl stre okay
um DJ do me a favor and let's do this
[__] this is uh this is fun cuz uh yeah
drop it but you don't know this about me
gr up I wanted to be a rapper that was
my goal and u i i i love I I love
celebrating people like you love
celebrating our Australian our kiwi and
our Seth afrian and we'll do that in in
song right now for you and the rest of
you can enjoy it and sit there going
[__] I'm glad it's not me that this
white boy's going to rap
about Trio in the front row certainly
the best of friends Commonwealth you
better know starting the South African
she going there like yo this fella is a
friend dating her and NSA Mandela is a
great guy let me set this really
straight if he was here I would have him
as a date but sadly pastor way he was
inside for like 40 years but came out
with pride that was my country separated
like a part but don't worry let me work
financial side I can't avoid this keep
the people out of prison but only
financial crimes yeah the derision I get
thrown at me I go far away I was in
Sydney like in Australia they got the
rocks in the opera house and sound
really weird whenever they flap their
mouth they're like good night M yeah
look at you Sydney's got a zoo and
kangaroos that's all of the [__] that we
like to show we got emu and Cy bar give
it a go and he's nodding he's like yes I
adore you when you talk about our flora
and fora I didn't do South African
accent I'll admit to you it would defend
you cuz it's sounds like I'm from India
if I try and do a diplomatic Community
or Russian or something like that it's
true to see this guy you do the same job
but then you mooved to New York and
thank God cuz you met an incredible New
Zeal land she's wonderful she's like do
you understand my client is called Apple
they be so cool Tim cup Johnny IES act
in the fool both of those don't work for
them anymore one of them left the other
one is under the floor because he died
ever so sad feeling lonely You' be
advertising like buy your iPhone 3 and
four and five up to 15 it's easy to
advertise it's so Nifty it's like a
license to print all of that money but
one day you'll fly you might sound
pretty funny like
hello welcome to New Zealand This Is How
They sound let's see if we we're going
to Wellington we're going to Oakland
we're going to go here oh we'll pull in
our Landing here this is really true she
ping with flying colors that's you
you're going to nail it and let's
impress the beautiful dress she wants to
be an actress like I'll act on screen
and we people will say she's still just
like meril Street and when they say the
Oscar for the best actor goes to I'll
say actress yes because I chose to
gender all the roles male and female
going on the big screen but sadly she
failed but don't worry you'll make more
money this way cuz they're on strike
actually today and so they can't do it
but you can still be employed my man
here the question he tried to avoid is
like oh [__] I thought I'd answer this
smoothly [__] in my brain what's my
favorite movie I can't say something
[__] like Love Actually I'll say good
godfa him he'll back to me he's like one
two or three and I'll say bro all the
one with robero or alino or marando or
other names that n with o it's really
easy to rap with those Italians bro
because they all right or one simple vow
you were like not three yes I'll allow
the first one mad respector I'll be a
director kicking back there in the black
fabric nice chair maybe but I can really
understand you if I fail at making
movies I'll just [__] roll the
camera
you are all delightful my name is Chris
T thank you very